es wird immer klarer dass die erde einem
wahren asteroiden bombardements
ausgesetzt ich ständig schwirren um uns
ziemlich großer brocken herum sie kommen
masse nichts und sind mega gefährlich
der solid der gerade an uns vorbei
gerast ist hatte die sprengkraft von
mehreren dutzend atombomben wäre ja
eingeschlagen hätte er locker eine
großstadt vernichten können danke an
stefan burger aus der web community die
das thema vorgeschlagen hat also
herzlich willkommen bei klick zum
science fiction ja schon zahlreiche
asteroiden ein schläger haben mir auf
der erde für riesige katastrophe gesorgt
und das scheint keine erscheinung der
vergangenheit zu sein wir werden wohl
ständig bombardiert und es gibt auch
ständig ein schläger auf der erde ohne
dass wir es bemerken dieser 50 meter ass
zählt also ein ziemlicher brocken kamen
der erde gefährlich nahe 200.000
kilometer das ist die halbe entfernung
zwischen erde und mond und in kosmischen
maßstäben nichts fast ein treffer und
und das ist erschreckend er wurde erst
21 stunden vorher überhaupt entdeckt
vorher schwirrte 2018 jeffrey unerkannt
durch unser sonnensystem und es werden
immer mehr von diesen erdnahen
asteroiden entdeckt wenn sie entdeckt
werden im jahr 2000 kannten wir nur 1000
jetzt sind es schon knapp 20.000 die die
umlaufbahn der erde kreuzen und bekannt
sind und jedes jahr werden eben mehr
entdeckt asteroiden sind ein
überbleibsel von der entstehung unseres
sonnensystems die meisten von ihnen
ziehen glücklicherweise weit entfernt
von der erde ihre runden um die sonne
zwischen den planeten mars und jupiter
das wachstum der entdeckung der erdnahen
asteroiden ist übrigens ex potenziell
und das finde ich wirklich alarmierend
ich hatte ja schon öfter hier darüber
berichtet und es ist ja einer meiner
lieblingsthemen wir unterschätzen die
gefahr solcher asteoriden 2018 sie zwar
um einiges größer als der asteroid der
im februar 2013 über russland explodiert
war die explosion des termins hatte
damals lediglich eine druckwelle
ausgelöst sie beschädigte mehrere
tausend gebäude und für
rund 100 menschen ein einschlag hätte
dagegen die stadt komplett zerstört
verglichen mit der hiroshima bombe hatte
er die 20 bis 40 fache sprengkraft
entsprechend tnt war es die von 600 kilo
tonnen 2018
die tri hätte also viel schlimmere
auswirkungen gab die erde ist ständig
bedroht von kollisionen mit erdgas 7
viele objekte sind klein und verglühen
in der atmosphäre ohne dass wir es
bemerken dass ein himmelskörper in die
atmosphäre eindringen und explodiert
oder anschlägen kommt allerdings öfter
vor als wir denken
wie oft das in den letzten 13 jahren
passiert es wurde ja erst kürzlich
bekannt werden darüber berichtet 26
asteroiden sind auf der erde
eingeschlagen darauf kommen sind
bekommen findige wissenschaftler sie
hatten die idee beim weltweiten
atomteststopp überwachungs netzwerk
nachzufragen ob es andere größere
explosionen auf der erde gab als
atombombenexplosion es waren 26
lediglich ein einschlag wurde dabei
vorher gesehen alle anderen kamen im
wahrsten sinne des wortes aus heiterem
himmel wie jetzt 2018
sie ist für jedes jahr schlagen also
zwei größere asteroiden hier auf der
erde ein
bisher hatten wir großes glück denn die
gesteinsbrocken schlugen im meer wüsten
oder sonstigen unbewohnten gebieten ein
jetzt haben die usa ja die neue behörde
planetary die fans koordination
gegründet sie soll erdgas soliden
entdecken und verfolgen die nasa hat
jetzt das ziel bis 2020 alle erdnahen
asteroiden die größer sind als 140 meter
zu entdecken nach immerhin schon etwas
denn genau diese könnten der erde sehr
gefährlich werden und mehr als nur eine
statt vernichten experten plädieren
deshalb immer wieder für eine bessere
weltweite zusammenarbeit und den aufbau
eines koordinierten frühwarnsystems
wirklich effektive abwehrstrategien sind
neumann nicht ausgetüftelt wir hätten in
diesem fall einen anschlag nicht
verhindern können deshalb hat die nasa
zusammen mit dem kernwaffen dabei
lawrence livermore national laboratories
jetzt das projekt hama gestartet hemmer
steht für high velocity edition mission
for emergency response auf deutsch über
geschwindigkeit asteroiden entschärfung
mission für notfallmaßnahmen es geht
wirklich zum ersten mal darum die
kuban eines asteroiden gezielt zu
beeinflussen das wäre eine wahnsinnig
wichtige zivilisations leistung ohne die
wir auf dauer wahrscheinlich nicht
überleben würden
wenn er als erstes neues zum thema hast
du ihn einschläge und zu allen anderen
themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
und zur begrüßung gibt es noch ein
kleines geschenk einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht was
aber mit der immer mit der glocke
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
dabei auch darauf liegt az rast auf die
erde zu
nasa plant bombardierungen da gibt es
mehr zu diesem thema was die nasa davor
hat ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran